so um i defeated level eight
it's time to move on oh rating twelve
hundred
so the scholars mate probably won't work
or they do challenge again oh i'm white
again am i just white every game
i wanted to play a stafford gambit
let's see what she plays
oh is she gonna play a staffer gambit
um actually bishop c5 could transpose
if knight c6 takes takes
okay this is just garbage for black no
offense
you select the color before you start
the game
i guess i didn't realize that good to
know
okay so this is very very pleasant
beth is violating all the opening
principles
and getting forked probably getting
forked multiple times because e5 is
coming
let's go saw so many things are attacked
wow that's a legal move
i don't know how many people know this
but you can legally castle
even when there's a knight here as long
as the king is not
attacked or moving through check
so my pawn is pinned
actually but
i can take a bishop and also deliver
check
and now attack the queen i just want to
chase the queen away from the e-file
[Music]
okay let's castle attacking the knights
getting the king safe
and now queen g4 threatening the knight
and threatening mates
that's actually a good move
bath realizing threats
um
is this knight trapped a knight is kind
of trapped
have this move knight has no safe
squares
oh d5 wow
if i on po song i'd lose a queen
oh wait let's play queen h4 d5 was a
good move
thankfully if i lose the bishop i win
the knight
and she's playing well already
okay f3 g5 what does this move
what is this queen h5
everything is still under control i
think
i have i have 75 of a central pawn cube
i think my goal this game is just to get
a pawn cube now
or just to mate probably to meat
let's check oh no my queen oh no
checkmate let's go
that was nice i feel kind of bad but not
really because my opponent's not
actually human
so i can i guess i can hurt its feelings
all i want
oh i i didn't even realize it's it's
trying it's talking to me
i hate losing oh now i kind of feel bad
but losing is learning right
losing is learning as long as you have
the right perspective
okay that was fun this final position
i hope i didn't offend anyone
i should kind of pay attention to what
she's saying i guess
okay does that require any analysis
i mean
yeah it was a free pawn and it was free
center
but sometimes at like the lower levels
it's just about taking free stuff
and making sure you're not giving away
anything for free
so yeah like the key to succeeding at
low levels is just
pretend that every day is your birthday
and then just keep taking presents and
don't give anyone else presents
a key to winning okay let's let's move
on let's um
that was age nine new game
so now we're moving on to
[Music]
age 10 rated 1600 ooh
it gets stronger or she got stronger i
should say
so when i click this oh
i'll click random okay this is good to
know
i didn't see these buttons before
play the queen's gambit oh well i'm
black i want to play a staffer gambit
will she go into it
staffer gambit time against oh
she's playing d4 i really wanted a
stafford
can i just resign
no i have a perfect score i can't resign
i have to suffer
with whatever this is so i'll take
i'll see how how much theory she knows
so quindi oh yeah she knows theory yeah
queen d4 is the main line
and she knows on passant too
impressive have to take with knight
this is still theory
at some point i'll get a stafford and
she's playing
and she's playing all like the gm moves
um bishop d6 here
and she's only 1600 okay we're going to
simplify
and eventually hopefully she'll blunder
before i blunder
a lot of tension between the queens
yeah this is much more difficult than
the the first two games save the bishop
wow what is g4
and g4 is um is interesting
[Music]
but probably
wait what is g4 it's probably weakening
at some point my bishop will be staring
down the pawn
i want to do this but uh then my knight
is kind of overworked
so i think the the better approach here
is to take the bishop first
if white takes back i'll play knight oh
but my pawn
okay thankfully i have h6
i think it's still okay i'm getting i'll
play the
hmm she saw my plan
but she didn't take g5 so that's a good
sign
i don't think i'm better here
but this is kind of sketchy play from
white
like the knights almost trapped let's
start with c3 or c6
preventing bishop d5 i want to play f6
and just trap the knight
f4 with a move
okay gonna be hoppity-hoppity with a
knight oh it's a fork let's go
[Music]
bam the fork knight has appeared
up until 93 like i wasn't entirely
comfortable
but now i'm very very comfortable
yeah and now we're gonna i'm gonna force
this and then takes and then f5
get some nice kind of pawn oh what is
this move
did i get too comfortable
i got kind of comfortable
[Music]
oops
i wanted to play this and hold on i'm
gonna lose that five
i let my guard down but it's okay i'm
gonna win this pawn
yeah it's still completely winning this
is not the cleanest game though
okay let's show some
end game technique in the end game to
win positions like this
uh you want to activate all your pieces
especially your king
and then probably eventually the rook
have you ever wondered if maybe pieces
don't actually move but
instead an identical copy is created at
the new square and the old piece just
kills itself via
apoptosis like in the prestige uh
um i don't know if i understand
oh like um what was the word you used
apoptosis
sounds poppy yeah end games are all
about making past pawns
okay i'm gonna do this
can i pre-move mate
maybe not quite okay we'll corral the
king
no let's actually let's win a pawn
wait what i lost track of the position
you just have to be careful not to
stalemate
there we go okay does this make me a
bully i don't know